[Music]
all right welcome back the copic
concerns are affecting every single team
in the nfl for the raiders boy it hit an
entire group of players
they will never have to send the entire
offensive line home again this season
that is for sure it's been a crazy week
those players tested negative the
morning of the game
and then they were allowed to play that
afternoon so they had to
well really no practice all week but the
raiders were coming off of by week so
they had a little prep time
biggest concern now for the raiders is
defense offensively they're scoring
points
points or other but just not stopping
anybody las vegas their defense ranked
26th in the league
it's been a season-long problem for the
silver and black and there's some
changes coming
we're going to try to get the best four
out there that we can number one whether
it involves more blitzing we'll see
who goes inside who goes outside who's
on the left side who's on the right side
what stunts we call what blitzes we call
everything is on the table we've been
meeting since very early in the morning
and uh we're going to play better on
defense i'm determined to make sure we
prove that this week
all right looking at the afc teams
raiders defense ranked 14th out of 16
teams
if you're wondering about the offense
board they're ranked ninth in the league
and fourth
among all afc teams they've got to find
a way in a hurry though tom brady
torched the raiders for four touchdown
passes on sunday
this week they face cleveland and baker
mayfield guess what he threw five
touchdowns and by the way
browns are favored by three at home so
probably be a pick em game if it was at
a neutral site browns
will have a limited number of fans in
the stands how about some